mama June is a grandma again  [Music]  boren Chanin aka pumpkin and boyfriend  Joshua Brandon effort welcomed their  first child on Friday and announced the  happy news on Twitter along with a sweet  pic of the newborn quote everyone meet  Ella grace effort the 17 year old  reality star revealed she was expecting  in a promo for the second season of Mama  June from not too hot I'm really excited  to be a new mom but there is some  challenges that I am glad to face I'm  really nervous about having a baby  cousin he just hasn't come on my long  pumpkin who is the older sister of here  comes honey boo boo star Alana Thompson  kept fans updated on her pregnancy in  August she shared this sonogram of her  little one on Facebook and she revealed  the sex of her baby in October biting  into a cupcake to find pink frosting  it's a girl and I'm freaking Tojo  pumpkin  [Music]  you